viajemos nuevamente al universo que
solamente tiene un granjero y un
constructor y pensemos en otro escenario
pensemos en un escenario diferente al
que teníamos en el ejemplo anterior
pensemos en un escenario donde el
granjero y el constructor tienen
abundante moneda a digamos que nuestro
granjero aquí tiene cinco monedas de oro
sí bueno mejor las voy a dibujar para
que sea más divertido entonces sus cinco
monedas de oro y que también el
constructor tiene cinco monedas de oro
pero entrando este año el granjero está
algo pesimista entonces se dirige al
constructor y le dice hola constructor
si de hecho es una granjera y hay
química entre ellos le dice hola al
constructor solo solo quiero la base de
construcción o mantenimiento sólo puedo
pagarte una moneda por tu servicio
entonces le da la moneda al constructor
y luego el constructor se siente algo
pesimista porque por lo regular la
granjera inicia el año de una mejor
entonces el constructor dice no seguro
este año será pésimo y se dirige a la
granja en itá y claro no le dice que
tiene todas esas monedas entonces dice
mira granjero y está hermosa me estoy
preparando para lo peor ahora solo dame
lo básico en alimento lo necesario para
sobrevivir
entonces el constructor de edad solo una
moneda la granjera ahora imaginad que
los recursos de dinero por alguna razón
aumentan la granjera está acabando en la
granja y encuentra más oro y el
constructor también construyendo
encuentra un enorme cofre de dinero pero
aún así ambos se sienten algo pesimistas
quizás simplemente son personas
pesimistas
entonces la granjera a pesar de
encontrar todo ese oro dice que es tan
frecuente me pasará esto en la vida solo
simplemente fue suerte el negocio no
está del todo bien mejor gasto lo menos
posible
entonces se dirige al constructor
constructor las cosas van empeorando
solo te puedo pagar media moneda por tus
servicios
y el constructor dice
ambas eso es peor que el año pasado pero
yo tengo tanta capacidad yo podría estar
construyendo más tengo a personas sin
empleo
claro claro claro granjel y está lo tomo
tomo tu media moneda por el mismo
servicio y así es lo hace le hace el
mismo servicio por la media moneda
entonces él ve que esencialmente sus
precios han bajado a pesar del hecho de
que hay más dinero encontró todo ese
dinero construyendo y se siente aún peor
el precio por lo que él ofrece bajo
entonces va con la granjera y le dice
mira necesito comprar esa comida o morir
de hambre pero la economía está por los
suelos no le dije la gran gélida que
encontró ese cofre de dinero entonces le
dice le dice a la granjita granjel y
está solo te puedo pagar media moneda
por tu comida y la granjera dice bueno
supongo piensa pues sus servicios
de construcción han bajado yo puedo
comprar más con esa media moneda
claro tomaré tu moneda tu media moneda
por lo mismo de comida que la tomé el
año pasado entonces ves esta situación
de deflación a pesar de que los recursos
han aumentado y claro estoy exagerando
normalmente si esto pasará en la vida
real las personas se pondrían optimistas
y empezarían a gastar dinero y aunque
quizás no se haría deflación puede ser
pero aquí el principal punto es darnos
cuenta de que la deflación no sucede por
la cantidad de moneda que tenemos es
importante pero tan importante como la
confianza es todas las transacciones de
dinero entonces la cantidad es
importante pero la cantidad por la
velocidad es lo que realmente maneja el
nivel en los precios